I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense comedy became the rage in the
middle of the 70s dare okay so in the
mid 70s disco was big so I told you I
don't dance I didn't go that's when
studio 54 I'm very high yeah I'm in my
mid 60's now so so I went to a comedy
club I'd never seen stand-up comedy live
and they said from the stage the the
host of the show said you know we also
at midnight we have amateurs can get up
if you think you have the chops to do it
and somebody said to me you should do it
now and okay because I don't ever
because of my mental health issues I
just am very impulsive and I never think
of ramifications so I just said okay and
I thought that would be the joke and I
didn't prepare and people who are
listening at home should know that
Danica does prepare but not use disease
let me do a homework I saw you going
over your questions but I don't prepare
and I said okay I'll go onstage I didn't
write any material and if you look at
old YouTube tapes of me you could tell I
don't have material and and I thought
the joke would be and I never aspired to
be in show business or to be an actor to
be a comedian and they said somebody
said ladies and gentlemen Howie Mandel
and I thought that'll be the joke and I
walked out there and I thought I did it
and then I look out into the audience
and there's people waiting I mean I
didn't think that there'd be people
there and I didn't think I didn't think
I don't think I didn't think about
you're great you live in the present
very well I don't other why I'm
medicated but I do but I'm also suffer
from anxiety and we'll talk about that
in a second but I got I got on stage and
they were looking at me and I thought oh
my god they're waiting for something so
I started if you look at the tapes I'm
very frenetic it's fear and I start
going okay okay okay okay all right all
right listen to this and I had nothing
but they started giggling at my nervous
tension of going okay and I go what what
what and that was like my act was what
okay okay well do this and because I'm a
germaphobe and I have all these things I
carry rubber gloves with me because I
didn't want to touch and this was years
before Purell years before access to I
didn't want to go into public restrooms
so I carry rubber
gloves and I just pulled it out and I
went okay okay okay and I just pulled it
on my head and I started breathing one
too low my nose and the fingers were
going up and down the audience was
roaring and it popped off my head and
the host came to me and said you got to
come back tomorrow and I went okay I
don't know for what but that be get that
rubber glove on I thought that was a
stripper story what no is that not the
stripper story
what's the stripper stuff I have a
stripper story I thought you had a
stripper story no what is my story make
it up it sounds fun my dad owned a like
a club yeah and that there was a
stripper that you'd see a stripper every
now and again as a kid this stripper was
naked and like in a bathtub well I know
that that's a different story there's
nothing to do with rubber glove oh well
you should tell her first story then
what's not a story it's not like I might
my dad had a great sense of humor so he
had a club uh-huh up in Canada and it
was a club it was in a hotel it was a
bar but sometimes he'd have this
stripper called Princess glow I was like
eight years old if she was a 350 pound a
naked woman in a giant champagne glass
who would soap herself up then get out
of the the glass and walk around the
room and drop her soapy breasts on bald
men's head
you